the term Consciousness has been forged
in response to the known fact that if
anything we are conscious
[Music]
can an AI system be intelligent uh first
and foremost and then conscious as a
consequence somehow of being intelligent
in order to address that in this first
part let me try to answer the question
what intelligence consists intelligence
to the extent to which AI research is
capable of modeling it this is my first
hypothesis now is first and foremost the
capacity paradigmatically of an animal
and if extendable to non-living systems
then also of some other entities of
solving a given problem in a finite
amount of time now that capacity is
measurable along the following very
simple Dimension a system s is more or
less intelligent if a system as Prime if
and only if it solves the same given
problem faster respective roughly slower
than the first system so in that respect
for instance solving my morning problem
of getting caffeine and as much of it as
possible as soon as possible it is more
intelligent to use the Nespresso machine
that I use than to boil in a long
ceremony some coffee or other because I
get the desired result much faster so
the use of my Nespresso machine in that
respect is more intelligent with respect
to the problem of maintaining ecological
balance on planet Earth it might be less
intelligent than some other way of
brewing and producing and consuming
coffee so along a certain problem
setting Dimension we can measure
intelligence in that more or less
well-defined conceptual sense and
thereby therefore we also celebrate and
welcome technological progress generated
by AI research because it leads to new
AI systems we which can help us to solve
our problems faster such as certain
problems and chess so many problems that
arise in science and other everyday
problems such as navigating a
complicated City finding the shortest
path and the nearest grocery store and
so forth and also connecting with our
friends or manipulating voters opinion
opinions if this is our interest in
using AI systems so that is arguably the
sense in which AI research is engaged in
producing outcomes that at least
contribute to our intelligence and which
many count as intelligent in themselves
so if you think that alphago is an
intelligent chess player or go player
than what you think about that system is
that the system all by itself is engaged
in problem-solving activities and solves
the same problems that we post to
ourselves namely what's the best move in
a given chess and game him say faster
than any known biological intelligence
so that's the Assumption so that is what
AI is now I want to argue that AI
systems are not actual thinkers and in
that sense they're not intelligent but
thought models so the nature of an AI
system is to be a model of the way in
which humans actually think and thereby
also the way in which humans are two
things so AI systems can surpass us in
many activities from more or less
Elementary pattern recognition in data
sets say up to skills that we very much
cherish such as chess playing or playing
go and other intellectual activities
certain mathematical proofs and so forth
so that is something that seems to
threaten human intelligence because
these systems to the extent to which
they model are our intelligence
surpasses but on closer inspection a
thought model of course needn't be
intelligent in itself just like a model
of a city needn't be a city to be sure
many models share the relevant property
with the target system that their models
off so if I plot a model of a city in
the Netherlands in order to predict
certain problematic outcomes of climate
warming and and catastrophic
catastrophic human-made climate change
if I do this then I do actually flood
something but I don't necessarily flood
a city because we don't build Dutch
cities in order to then flood them so
but that means that some models of
course share some interesting and
relevant property of their target system
whereas other models share less but or
rather more formal properties such as
the model of the Black Forest which
doesn't consist of trees but of certain
representations of trees whereas the
actual Black Forest consists of trees so
a Google map of the Black Forest which
helps me to find a restaurant in the
Black Forest that differs more from the
Black Forest in certain respects than a
model of a Dutch City differs from a
Dutch City with respect to flooding so
they're different types of relationships
between models and what their models are
their target systems now in the AI case
I think that AI systems and AI research
model human thoughts but not human
thinking so what their model is The
Logical structure
or some other mathematically accessible
structure that characterizes the
relationship between our thoughts but
what they don't model are the activities
of our thinking because the activities
of our thinking and that's going to be
crucial in a minute in the second part
are as a matter of fact in human animals
biologically grounded so no argument to
the effect that there could be or even
is conscious AI should of course assume
that we are conscious AIS in a relevant
sense there has to be a distinction
between us and the system whose
Consciousness we want to question and
that difference lies in the other
element of the concept of AI namely in
the air in the a of the AI the
artificiality so AI systems other than
natural intelligence systems such as
bees and humans did not evolve in the
way in which we evolved we are
cell-based life forms highly complex and
organized life forms which are not even
nearly deciphered by the life and
Natural Sciences though we have made
considerable progress in particular over
the last 100 years or actually less
since the beginning of the discoveries
of molecular
genetics in particular but those
progresses of course all tell us that we
are essentially biologically grounded or
embodied as the saying goes but the AI
systems whose Consciousness is in
question in contemporary debates you
know could a natural language processing
system soon become conscious or is one
actually already conscious those are
debates which arise in manifold ways
almost every year in the face of the
rapid advances of computer science those
questions do not ask something about
given animals but precisely about
artificial systems that did not come
into existence through ordinary
biological evolution so we are thinking
about you know bluntly put silicon-based
structures and Chip based processing
rather than biology-based processing
that is characteristic of natural
intelligence and Consciousness as we
know it so the question should be could
something that is the non-biological
product of human industry something that
neither comes into existence through
ordinary sexual reproduction or cell
division nor through growing something
like cerebral organoids that is
artificially designed neural actually
neural systems could such a thing become
or already be conscious is the question
and to the extent to which the kinds of
things that we produce are as I just
argued thought models and not models of
thinking the answer is a clear no so the
question would be more like could the
Google Maps presentation of the Black
Forest turn into a bunch of trees and
the answer is of course not or it would
be very surprising to say that they're
released so if you post the question in
light of that analogy it becomes
entirely up obvious that the answer is a
clear no but this needs more
substantiation which is why I come now
to the second at least equally thorny
issue
namely what do we ask for when we ask
for Consciousness so what is the meaning
of Consciousness rather than what is
consciousness and the reason why I start
with the question of the meaning of
Consciousness rather than
straightforwardly with Consciousness is
that the term Consciousness in English
and other languages is highly
problematic and fraud in particular with
various philosophical histories so it's
not the case that we all know what we
mean when we say conscious so that we
can then just ask the question what the
relationship could be between AI systems
maybe clarified in the way in which I
did in part one if I'm right and
Consciousness which we know what it
would be if it existed right so assuming
that we all think Consciousness so much
as exists which I now assume because the
question is could AI is be conscious and
that presupposes that there is such a
thing as consciousness so I will take
that for granted but what do we mean by
Consciousness and now you get you know
philosophers answers such as the famous
answer well Consciousness is you know
what is it likeness Consciousness is the
feeling of life itself as
neuroscientists and neuro philosopher
Christopher has put it with a very nice
book title so Consciousness according to
that construe would be you know as a
worthy inner side of being me but that's
of course a very vague answer because
there are too many things that go on in
me in that interesting sense as I now
speak so uh you know which of the many
mental states that characterize My
overall mental state right now counts as
conscious that's the famous question not
only of the mark of the mental how do we
distinguish between something that's a
mind and something that's not a mind but
even more complicated what's the mark of
Consciousness so how do we distinguish
between something that's conscious and
something that's not conscious for
instance what's the relationship between
the conscious and the sub or
non-conscious parts of our minds so
those questions are not easily answered
and they're certainly not answered by
just being a competent user of the
English word Consciousness otherwise put
there are technical philosophical and
other scientific issues involved in
beginning to answer the question
concerning the very meaning of
Consciousness but one thing is certain
and this is going to be the important
part of my argument in the second part
of my talk namely that Consciousness the
term Consciousness in all its uses so
far has been forged in response to the
known fact that if anything we are
conscious which is why the reflexive
attitude of the famous kogito the
cartoon reason I think therefore I am
this reflexive attitude that is
consciousness getting a hold of itself
is quite constitutive of the very topic
of Consciousness many philosophers over
the centuries have therefore believed
that there cannot be such a thing as
Consciousness without self-consciousness
Consciousness seems to be constitutively
related to itself in such a way that you
cannot have or be it without somehow
noticing that you have or are it you
cannot be conscious without noticing
that you are which raises the question
of the relationship between first order
Consciousness the state or event
structure that you're in and you are
getting hold of it on something that
seems to be a second mental state which
is why of course some theorists of
Consciousness even argue that
Consciousness is that difference between
a first order and a second order state
that would lead into the field of
so-called higher order theories of
consciousness I've only mentioned in
this not because I want to decide
between the available philosophical
theories of Consciousness on some ground
or other but only because my intention
is to point out that Consciousness
refers the term Consciousness refers to
something that's that I am acquainted
with in virtue of having or being it now
who is this entity that is acquainted
with whatever Consciousness is well an
animal
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas